Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain the American epic science fiction film
called “Dune.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie Dune is set in the year 10191. Humans
have unfolded many secrets of the universe and
now travel from planet to planet. Different
planets have turned into different nations and
are governed by a single Padishah Emperor named
Shaddam Corrino IV. The planets have “houses”
with their respective dukes who in turn follow the
orders of the emperor Shaddam. One of such planets
is the planet of Arrakis. It is a harsh desert
planet that is the only source of a rare substance
called "spice". Spice is a valuable substance
that extends human vitality and is critical for
interstellar travel. Hence, Arrakis, despite its
harsh conditions, is considered the most valuable
planet in the known universe. Because of this,
the noble houses are eager to rule the planet.
At the beginning of the movie, a native of the
Arrakis named Chani narrates that they have been
ruled by the noble House Harkonnen for a long
time. The House Harkonnen is cruel to natives
of Arrakis but the poor natives cannot fight
House Harkonnen which is under the emperor
Shaddam’s control. Chani also says that one
day, all of a sudden, House Harkonnen’s troops
leave Arrakis. But she is sure that the
emperor is going to send someone else to
take their place and exploit their resources.
The scene then changes to another planet named
Caladan ruled by House Atreides. The prince of
Atreides, Paul wakes up from a recurring dream. He
has breakfast with his mother Lady Jessica who is
also a member of an organization called the Bene
Gesserit. Bene Gesserit is an exclusive sisterhood
organization whose members have advanced physical
and mental abilities. Hence, Jessica also
has the power to manipulate people’s minds.
She has been training Paul the organization’s
disciplines for a long time. Thus, Paul has powers
to see the future and bears other unique powers
that he is yet to discover. Paul’s father Leto,
who is also the duke of House Atreides, has
an important meeting with personnel from the
Landsraad, the political body representing all
the noble houses. In the evening, everyone in
Atreides welcomes the VIPs who have brought a note
from the emperor Shaddam himself. The emperor,
who has recently removed House Harkonnen from
the Arrakis, wants Atreides to take Harkonnen’s
place. He wants Leto and his troops to be in
charge of mining the “spice” from Arrakis.
Duke Leto is apprehensive of the situation
but follows the emperor’s orders. Whilst
in the meeting, Jessica notices a member of the
Bene Gesserit organization, Gaius Helen Mohiam,
staring at Paul. The meeting ends when Leto
marks a seal with his ring, confirming that
they will follow the orders and go to Arrakis.
In the following scene, we see Atreides's troops
preparing to leave for Arrakis. Among the troop
is their bravest soldier named Duncan who is
also Paul’s close friend. Paul has been getting
visions about Duncan’s death in Arrakis which
he is worried about. Duncan assures him that he
will be fine and leaves for the planet to prepare
for Paul and the family’s arrival. The following
scene shows us Paul and his father Leto talking
about various matters. Leto reveals that he has
no interest in gaining wealth using the spice,
instead, he plans on befriending the
people of Arrakis called the Fremen.
Unlike the former duke, Harkonnen, he
plans to treat the Fremen with respect
so they can be a valuable asset to Atreides.
Later, Paul and his associate, Halleck practice
a duel. They have a wrist device that creates
a layer of protective force around their body.
Halleck is worried that they will be attacked
by the jealous Harkonnen, so he asks Paul to
be careful when they reach Arrakis. Elsewhere,
in the house of Harkonnen the former ruler of
Arrakis, duke Baron and his rogue nephew Rabban
talk about their last ship leaving the Arrakis,
leaving the planet to the Atreides. Rabban
belittles the emperor for taking them off
Arrakis and handing it to the Atreides. But he
is surprised when Baron reveals that the emperor
is actually planning on the Atreides’s downfall
because he is jealous of their growing popularity.
The emperor’s plan is to kill Leto and all his
men when they are mining spice in Arrakis.
Back in the Caladan, Jessica wakes Paul
up and takes him to a doctor to get his
vitals checked. It turns out that the Reverend
Mother Gaius Helen Mohiam has come to know of
Paul’s visions and wants to check if he is
‘the one’ they have been waiting for.
She makes him put his hands on a box and test
his impulse control, which he passes with
great effort. After Mohiam leaves, Jessica
tells Paul that the female organization,
Bene Gesserit, has been steering the politics
for years from the shadows. And they have also
been carefully crossing bloodlines in order
to give birth to the one man who will have the
potential to save Arrakis from spice exploitation.
It turns out the test Paul just passed shows him
to be the one they have been looking for,
The Messiah Of Arrakis. The very next day,
Leto, Paul, Jessica, and their troops leave for
Arrakis and land on the planet. They are welcomed
by the native Fremen who have already been told
that Paul is their messiah, although Paul himself
believes that it is just a superstition.
Later, he is in his chamber learning about a
massive sandworm found in Arrakis. To be safe
from it, the Fremen walk in irregular motions
in the sand. As Paul watches holograms,
a deadly insect emerges from a wall
and tries to kill him. But Paul saves
himself at the right time. On investigating,
it is found that a Harkonnen soldier has
been hiding in the walls to kill Paul.
The scene shifts to Baron meeting Mohiam. She
knows about the emperor and Baron’s plan to
attack Atreides but cannot do anything because it
is the emperor’s order. However, she asks Baron
not to kill Jessica and Paul. Baron agrees to do
as she says, but plans to throw the two in the
sand for the sandworms to kill. Back on Arrakis, a
meeting is held where the officials discuss their
plan to mine the spices. It is revealed that the
Harkonnens have left them with damaged equipment,
setting them up for failure.
After a while, Paul reunites with
Duncan who had been sent to prepare for their
arrival. Duncan says that he has been living
with the Fremen in deserts for four weeks. He
tells them all about their ways to survive and
also about a Fremen community called Sietch and
their leader Stilgar. Stilgar has also come to
meet Leto. Leto offers him to work together
with the Atreides but Stilgar belittles him
from taking from their land without any returns
to the people of their land. They separate on a
good note after Leto promises to never harm the
Sietches. The next day, Leto and his team go to
inspect the spice sand that they will be mining
from. They meet a Freman and an imperial ecologist
named Dr. Liet-Kynes. She checks the integrity
of Leto’s sand suit which is supposed to recycle
sweat and urine from a person’s body into drinking
water. While checking Paul’s suit, Kynes notices
that he knows Fremen’s ways of wearing the suit
despite it being his first time. This makes her
think of a prophecy that says their messiah will
know their ways of life despite being from another
land. Kynes also believes Paul to be “the one”.
After that, all of them leave to inspect the spice
sand. While sightseeing, they see two sandworms
approaching the harvester that mines the spice.
It seems to be a usual problem as a carrier is
sent to lift the harvester to get it out of the
worm’s reach. However, the carrier’s anchor
breaks and it is unable to lift the machine.
A crew of 21 are inside the harvester who
are about to be attacked by the worms.
Leto thinks quickly and orders everyone to get
their aircraft closer to the device and get the
crew on board. They land on the sand minutes
before the worm attacks and manage to save the
crew. However, Paul sniffs whiffs of spice in the
process and gets a vision. When he returns home,
he is still dizzy and the doctor concludes
it as an allergy. However, Paul claims that
he saw a Fremen girl in his vision and he knows
it wasn’t just an allergy. He also tells Jessica
that she is pregnant but Jessica dismisses it.
The scene then shifts to the imperial army planet
where a battalion is being prepared to attack
Atreides and kill Leto and his family. They are
called the army of Sadukar who are said to be
the deadliest army in the known world. Back in
Arrakis, the doctor brings Paul a medicine to help
him with the allergies. But little does Paul know,
the doctor has made a deal with Baron and the
medicine will make Paul unconscious. Leto and
Jessica are also given medicines for their sleep.
Jessica takes it but Leto doesn’t. After a while
the army of Sadukar attacks them. Leto wakes
up and realizes what is happening. But before
he can do anything, the doctor hits him with a
dart that slowly makes him unconscious. Outside,
the Sadukar army wreaks havoc in the place
taking the Atreides’s army by surprise. Since
the Sadukar is double in number and has several
weapons, they soon overpower the Atreides.
At the same time, the doctor tells an
injured Leto that Baron has abducted his wife
so he had to do what he says. The doctor then
takes off Leto’s ring to give it to Paul.
He also places a poisonous molar tooth in
Leto’s jaw saying that if he bites hard enough,
the tooth with secret poisonous gas will kill
everyone around. Meanwhile, the Sadukar army
abducts Paul and Jessica to throw them in the
sand. Paul wakes up in an aircraft with his
mother gagged and tied beside him. She can use
her power to manipulate people and make them do
what they are told. So the two use their powers
and manage to kill their abductors. Paul finds a
fremkit placed by the doctor for their help. After
that, they escape in the middle of the desert.
In the meantime, an unconscious Leto is taken to
Baron and stripped naked. The doctor asks Baron
to free his wife but he is instead killed
mercilessly. Baron then tells Leto that his
bloodline will end today. Seeing no way to escape,
Leto bites onto his teeth and lets out a poisonous
gas that kills everyone in the room including
himself. Somewhere else, Paul and Jessica set up
a tent using the kit. They also find a note from
the doctor and Leto’s ring. Looking at the ring,
the two realize that Leto is dead and cry
mourning his death. The following morning,
Duncan approaches the Fremen Imperial ecologist
kynes, and asks her to help look for Paul and
Jessica. Back in Baron’s palace, his soldier come
into the room after the poisonous gas has faded.
They are surprised to see that Baron has attached
himself to the ceiling and is somehow safe.
At the same time, Paul gets high on the spice in
the sand and starts to get visions of the holy
war that is about to happen in the future.
He sees himself killing millions of people
and the deaths make him hyperventilate. A worried
Jessica calms her son down. Sometime later, he
wears his father’s ring, taking the title of duke
of Atreides. They are soon found by Duncan who
kneels in front of Paul calling him the lord duke.
Then all three of them are taken to a safe place
by Kynes. The place they are staying at is an old
ecological station that was supposed to provide
flowing water to Arrakis. If the project had been
successful, Arrakis would have been a paradise.
However, before the project was completed, the
spice was discovered in the sand. Everyone’s
attention was diverted towards harvesting the
valuable spice and the project was dismissed.
A while later, the Sadukar army reaches the safe
zone and attacks everyone. Duncan puts his life at
risk to save Jessica and Paul. Paul yells at him
to stop because he has seen Duncan’s death in his
vision but Duncan stays put to fulfill his duty.
Eventually, he is killed while fighting the army
but Jessica, Paul, and Kynes manage to run away.
Jessica and Paul get on an aircraft that only
holds two people. Meanwhile, Kynes asks them to
head south to meet the Fremen who will help them
in their cause. She plans to board an aircraft
from another station. The mother and son fly away
but Kynes is soon caught by the Sadukar soldiers.
They are about to kill her when she makes rhythmic
thumping on the ground. The noise attracts a
sandworm who kills all of them in one go.
After that, Paul’s aircraft is chased
by two enemy aircraft. Paul enters their
vehicle into an aggressive sand storm making
their enemies believe that they are dead.
In the following scene, we see Baron bathing
in medicines to heal the injuries caused by the
poisonous gas. His nephew Rabban arrives there and
tells him that Leto and his bloodline are dead.
Finally happy that his enemy house is destroyed,
Baron orders Rabban to continue to harvest the
spice and kill all the Fremen. Somewhere else,
Paul and Jessica crash land in the desert but
are safe. They change into the desert suit and
start looking for the Fremen to ask them for help.
Paul had learned about Fremen lives and knows
the way they walk to avoid attracting the worms.
They walk for the whole day throughout which
Paul gets visions of Fremen people and a
specific girl telling him to not give up.
The two stop to rest for a while when suddenly,
they hear a loud noise. Paul realizes that
a sandworm is nearby. To save their lives,
they start to run only to be chased by the worm
even faster. It emerges from the sand and is
about to engulf the two but stops midway.
Someone had set off a thumper to help them.
Just then, the leader of the Fremen
Stilgar, and his group surround them.
It is soon revealed that they plan to kill Paul
and Jessica for the fluids in their bodies.
Stilger stops his men saying that Paul is the
messiah they were told about. The others do not
believe him saying that Paul hasn’t yet proven
himself so he cannot be the messiah. One of them
insults Jessica calling her old and a weakling.
She proves herself by holding the man hostage
with his life in her hands. After that, the leader
asks everyone to make their way to the Sietch Tabr
where Paul and Jessica’s fate will be determined.
Just then, the girl from Pauls’ visions arrives
in front of him and introduces herself as Chani.
As they prepare to leave, one Fremen named Jamis
insists on having a duel with Paul.
In Fremen’s tradition, all duels must end
with someone’s death. Paul, who has been
training all his life easily defeats Jamis
but he hesitates to kill him because he
hasn’t killed anyone in his life. At last,
Paul stabs the man to death and wins the fight.
Then, the others pack the dead body and make their
way to the Sietch Tabr. The movie ends when
Paul sees a man riding a massive sandworm and
Chani tells him it is only the beginning. The
ending of the movie makes it clear that there
is much more to come in the sequels.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help the
channel out. Thanks for watching.